le lion veille toujours sur la citadelle
et sur la ville
durant l'hiver 1870 103 jours de guerre
vont changer le destin d'une petite cité
à l'heure alsacienne
depuis belfort l'assiégé n'a jamais
cessé d'entretenir la mémoire de ses
défenseurs héros anonymes d'une guerre
souvent oubliée
[Musique]
en juillet 1870 napoléon iii déclare la
guerre à la prusse en septembre
l'empereur et défaire ce dans la
république est proclamée et la guerre va
continuer belfort qui occupe une
position stratégique en alsace compte à
l'époque près de 7000 habitants belfort
est une petite ville en fête en 1870 qui
a qu'à bénéficier en fait du début de la
révolution industrielle puis ce qu'on a
on a quand même au moins une manufacture
la ville accueille le chemin de fer
depuis 1858 donc c'est une ville qui
commence en fait un mort c'est gérer une
mutation économique
c'est une ville de garnison avec un
régiment d'infanterie un régiment de
cavalerie la citadelle existait déjà
les fortifications scinder la ville
l'homme qui commande la place s'appelle
denfert rochereau
il a parfaitement préparé la défense de
la ville et de ses environs alors que le
son des canons est encore loin des
milliers de soldats rejoindre belfort
la falloir héberger ces hommes qui ne
sont pas des militaires aguerris
puisqu'ils l'ont été ils ont été levées
durant l'été ils arrivent avec des
moyens matériels qui sont très limitées
puisque ce sont les départements à la
mairie qui finance l'équipement de ces
soldats de fortune
ils proviennent de départements très
diverses
on va avoir principalement des sols des
jeunes hommes qui viennent du rhône
département de lyon de saône et loire
du côté de notamment de chalon sur saône
on va avoir des artilleurs qui lui
arrive de toulouse de la région de la
haute garonne
rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter l'armée
prussienne début novembre 1870 elle
encercle la ville
c'est le début du siège
une partie de la population a décidé de
quitter la ville on les vit à lui à peu
près à deux mille 2000 personnes avant
le siège qui ont quitté la ville mais on
sait que par exemple il ya un train qui
a fait partir en direction de besançon
qui ne pourra pas le faire
le 3 novembre 1870 c'est à dire que ces
personnes n'ont pas pu être évacués mais
on sait aussi qu'il ya toute une
population villageoise des alentours qui
vont venir se mettre sous la protection
de belfort
les images qui témoignent du calvaire
que va subir belfort sont rares
certaines sont conservés au musée
d'histoire ou bien encore ici aux
archives départementales dans cette
boîte vous avez un ensemble de fonds
photographiques dont une partie qui
représente des photos qui ont été prises
par les photographes gars tu écoutes
celles ci sont vraiment pris sur le vif
au milieu des débris de ce siège et on
voit donc vraiment tel que c'est la
photographie réaliste du cercle 1876 les
prussiens espérait une reddition rapide
ils se trompent ils surnommeront bientôt
belfort lattes automne fabrique la
fabrique de mort